RETO MEIER: Today I learned
that when it snows in New York,
manhole covers go missing.
Summertime means long city bike
rides, dead trees, and rats.
And, well, something
happens with dogs in July.
I'm Reto Meier, Google
developer advocate.
Join me as I use the call
function, 30 gigabytes
of weather records, and 130 gigs
of New York City public data
to investigate correlations,
if not causations,
with weather in New York
City, with BigQuery.
Trapped in the unchanging,
timeless stasis
of this top secret and totally
real Google data center,
I don't get much in
the way of weather.
But that doesn't mean
I can't use BigQuery
to see how the weather
affects the lucky people who
get to experience Outer World.
For example, as the
temperature rises into the 70s,
people take more city bike
trips, and more of those rides
start from the outer boroughs.
That's not really surprising.
Where it gets interesting is
the unexpected correlations,
like snow and missing
manhole covers.
To find more weather
correlations,
we need to dig through
200 gigabytes of data.
BigQuery is fast
and cheap, but it'll
be faster and cheaper if we make
our data a bit more manageable.
The NOAA global
summary of day tables
include a dozen
weather variables
recorded from 9,000 stations
dating back to 1929.
And we don't need all of that.
We'll extract just the weather
variables we need and replace
the 999.99 values, which
are used to represent null,
with zeros, so that our averages
make a little bit more sense.
Airports tend to provide
the best weather data.
And in New York, that
means LaGuardia and JFK.
So we'll select just those and
average their daily records.
The NOAA tables
are split by year,
so let's combine everything
from 2009 to 2016,
the date range for our
New York data sets.
Saving the result
to its own table
results in a very
manageable 200 kilobytes.
Now, using our
weather table, let's
see if temperatures have
any effect on cab rides.
Unlike the city
bikes, this graph
doesn't show a strong pattern.
But what other interesting
patterns can we find?
We all know that correlation
doesn't imply causation.
But maybe, if we're just looking
for interesting patterns,
we can use correlations
as a way of finding them.
Calculating correlation
is a pain in the [DING].
It's hard, and graphing every
possibility would take forever.
But thankfully,
BigQuery includes
the call function to do
all the hard work for us.
This query returns
the correlations
between each of our
weather variables
and each of the primary causes
of motor vehicle accidents.
The results table
suggests two possibility--
accidents caused by slippery
pavements related to snow,
and wind gusts related
to runaway cars.
Graphing both against
time, there's some evidence
that slipping
accidents increases
when there's heavy snow.
What about gusty winds
pushing runaway cars
down the streets of New York?
I'd like it to be true, but
does the data support it?
Well, let's say for now
it's too early to tell.
We've only got data for runaway
cars for the last four months.
And when we graph it, there's
just not enough there.
So where to next?
BigQuery includes every
municipal complaint
made to 311, so there's dozens
of different complaint types
that we can try and link
to weather patterns.
Using the call
function, I ran queries
to find the top correlations for
temperature, snow depth, wind
speed, wind gusts, and rain.
The most likely candidates?
Temperature relationships with
heating complaints, dead trees,
and rat sightings, snow
depth relationships
with missing manhole
covers and illegal parking,
and higher wind speeds with
lower noise complaints.
You can find a link to the full
table and the queries here.
Now, it's no surprise that
the call volume for heating
complaints is
significantly higher
when the temperature is lower.
What is surprising was
a similar correlation
between missing manhole
covers and snow depth.
So either the Abominable
Snowman is a New Yorker
with a penchant
for manhole covers,
or, if we have our
causation reversed,
manhole covers are what's
preventing New York from being
swallowed by a snowpocalypse.
Now, whether it's a snowman or
a snowpocalypse, when graphed
over time, there is a
fairly consistent pattern
of heavy snow and reports
for missing manhole covers.
The amount of snow doesn't
seem that significant.
Maybe the holes in the
road are more noticeable
when the rest of
the street is white.
Snow depth and illegal parking
turns out to be a dead end.
But hydrant complaints are
trending up, as is snowfall.
And while double parking
had some coincident spikes
with heavy snow
in 2010 and 2016,
there wasn't really
much else there.
Either way, New Yorkers,
maybe stop parking
in front of fire hydrants?
Not cool.
You noticed that
there were a lot
of strong correlations with
temperature, such as complaints
about trees.
And the clearest
thing in this graph
is that there's a seasonal
pattern affecting both,
which is made even
clearer when you
look at the monthly averages.
So let's take those
monthly averages
and seasonally
adjust our results
to see if there's a pattern
beyond the time of year.
This graph measures
the proportion
of the month's
tree-related calls
to temperature minus
the monthly average.
And there's really not much
to speak of in terms of trend.
Now, wind speed had
a strong correlation
with noise complaints.
We know New York City has
windier weather in the winter,
so let's just seasonally
adjust for that right away.
If we graph all our
points as a scatterplot,
you can almost see
a relationship.
But there's also a lot of noise.
And here we've put our results
into buckets of one degree,
averaging the volumes
for each bucket.
And the relationship
is much clearer,
but it's also a
little bit deceptive.
It totally hides the variance
and gives undue weight
to the buckets at
the extremes that
represent far fewer
samples, which
is why we have the magic
of the hex spin graph.
Here we can graph all the
points within a given hex
and weight the
darkness of each hex
by the number of
points it contains.
As a result, we can see a
trend from the overall shape
of the distribution, as well
as a heat map of measurement
distribution.
For wind and noise, you can
see a triangular pattern
that implies a weak
negative correlation, which
suggests a greater likelihood
of getting more noise
complaints when the wind is
low and significantly fewer
calls when the
wind is five knots
above the monthly average--
particularly for loud
talking, which almost
gives us a band in a
diagonal line for both
the overall distribution and the
area of highest concentration.
[DOG BARKING]
Neither approach explains
barking dogs, though.
It's troubling.
Why do barking dog
complaints go down in summer?
What happens to the dogs?
Are they on vacation?
Do they share a house
in the Hamptons?
Are they locked outside?
Are they locked inside?
Why are they silent?
I think we've stumbled on
something here, something big.
We've got to get
the message out.
There's no telling--
[BEEP]
Check out the link below
to find the largest
subset of possible weather
complaints correlations.
And please, dig in to find other
nuggets hidden within the data.
As always, with Big Query, your
first terabyte of processing
each month is free.
Go to BigQuery today and
create your own New York City
visualizations and
share them with us
using the #TILwBQ hashtag.
And don't forget to check
out some of our other Today
I Learned videos
and the playlist.
And of course,
subscribe to our channel
and follow our blog to learn
something new with BigQuery.